ac à côté du problème et dans mes
souvenirs c'est la première fois qu'on
assiste à des manifestations de masse où
la majorité des américains sont
sympathisants de ces mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
près de douze mille soldats américains
vont quitter l'allemagne décision signée
donald trump le président américain
reproche au pays d'angela merkel de ne
pas contribuer à ces dans le budget de
l'otan des militaires qui seront
dispersées en italie et en belgique
[Musique]
saint malo en france ville très
touristique vient d'imposer le port du
masque en extérieur pour l'instant pas
de règles nationales en ce sens là sur
un autre plan de la pandémie que la
pandémie continue provoqué les tensions
entre eux médecin le professeur didier
rous grand défenseur de litres maxi
chloroquine a porté plainte contre les
directeurs des hôpitaux parisiens martin
hirsch a le premier ministre canadien
justin trudeau entendu par des soupçons
de fraude il va s'expliquer dans la
journée devant le comité permanent des
finances
il est soupçonné d'avoir octroyé sans
appel d'offres un contrat public de près
d'un milliard de dollars à des ong
oui charities
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur arte france la menace de
donald trump le président américain
voudrait retirer près de douze mille
soldats basés en allemagne
le locataire de la maison blanche estime
que les allemands n'honore pas à leurs
obligations dans le budget de l'otan et
reproche au pays d'angela merkel
d'acheter de l'énergie à la russie
l'allemagne achète à la russie de
l'énergie pour des milliards de dollars
chaque année et nous sommes censés
protéger l'allemagne de la russie
qu'est ce que c'est que tout ça en plus
l'allemagne est très en retard sur les 2
% de participation qu'elle doit à l'otan
c'est pour ça que nous redéployons des
troupes basées en allemagne ont fait le
point justement sur cette situation avec
notre correspondant à moscou entre une
clio oui avec le retrait des troupes
américaines du sol allemand donald trump
cherche donc à punir l'allemagne entre
autres pour sa volonté d'importer du gaz
russe mais aussi son soutien à la
construction du gazoduc nord stream de
l'allemagne se retrouverait donc si on
en suit le raisonnement américains plus
exposés plus vulnérables sans la
présence des troupes américaines mais
plus vulnérables à quoi telle est la
question posée par le représentant russe
auprès des instances internationales
regarder certains observateurs
interprètent le retrait de 12 mille
soldats américains d'allemagne comme une
punition pour berlin pourquoi
l'allemagne n'est pas menacée ainsi la
sécurité ne sera pas affectée
politiquement l'allemagne en profitera
probablement cela ne peut affecter
économiquement que les communautés
autour des bases américaines
on assiste donc un dangereux mélange des
genres du côté de washington pour
empêcher la russie de continuer à
exporter son gaz vers l'allemagne puis
vers le reste de l'europe
donald trump brandi l'otan et bouleverse
les équilibres sur le vieux continent
une décision dont on est sans doute
encore loin d'avoir mesuré toute
l'ampleur
c'est une affaire domestique des états
unis et c'est une question de relations
bilatérales entre washington et berlin
nous ne pouvons pas commenter ces
relations et nous ne nous immisçons pas
nous n'avons jamais caché que moins il
ya des militaires américains en europe
plus la situation il sera stable notre
position est bien connu d'autant plus
qu'après la confrontation entre les deux
blocs durant la guerre froide
il n'ya plus de menace évidente est réel
les menaces éphémère on peut les
inventer à loisir on assiste donc un
dangereux mélange des genres du côté de
washington pour empêcher la russie de
continuer à exporter son gaz vers
l'allemagne puis vers le reste de
l'europe
donald trump brandi l'otan et bouleverse
les équilibres sur le vieux continent
une décision dont on est sans doute
encore loin d'avoir mesuré toute
l'ampleur et si les élections
américaines été reportée c'est donald
trump lui même qui évoque l'idée à cause
de fraudes qui serait selon lui est liée
à l'épidémie coronavirus avec le vote
par correspondance 2020 sera l'élection
la plus inexacte et la plus frauduleuse
de l'histoire at-il twitté on le
rappelle le scrutin doit avoir lieu le 3
novembre ea prochain l efficacité de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine continue
d'alimenter les débats c'est le cas en
france mais aussi aux états unis un pays
où les chiffres sont alarmants avec près
de cent cinquante mille décès à donald
trump vante les mérites de cet anti
paludéens certains républicains
également un sujet de katia technique
les débats sur l'hydroxyde chloroquine
connaissent une flambée aux états unis
récemment de recherches américaines ont
établi que cet antiviral est efficace
pour traiter la maladie tandis qu'une
étude de l'institut national de la santé
et de la recherche médicale inserm et
une autre menée au brésil conclu qu'elle
n'a aucun effet cela ajoute à la
confusion ambiante dans les débats sur
le sujet aux états unis quoi qu'il en
soit l' agence fédérale compétente la
f10
ah bien révoquer l'autorisation
d'utilisation de la molécule pour le
traitement du kobe 19 le 15 juin dernier
mais au pays de donald trump bien plus
qu'ailleurs le ralliement à la molécule
s'effectue selon la couleur politique
elle est défendue majoritairement par
les anti système et les républicains et
conspué par les démocrates mais l'idéal
nombreux médecins pensent que c'est
extrêmement bénéfique
d'autres non je pense que c'est devenu
très politique harvey riche professeur
d'épidémiologie à l'université de yale
et partisan de ce traitement estime que
l'hydroxyde chloroquine est au centre
d'une guerre politique c'est un
traitement politique maintenant pas un
traitement médical je pense qu'on se
retrouve à se battre face à une guerre
de propagande contre les faits médicaux
mais en l'occurrence les adversaires de
la molécule controversée pourrait en
dire tout autant car ces derniers jours
la promotion de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
a pris un tour propagandistes dans une
vidéo des joyeux drilles d american
frontline doctors ce petit film devenu
viral le 27 juillet a été visionné des
centaines de millions de fois la vidéo a
même été retweeté par donald trump père
et fils problème son égérie stella
emmanuel à un esprit très fantaisiste
selon elle les etats-unis étaient il ya
peu dirigé par des esprits reptilien mi
humain mi extra terrestres
elle fustige aussi la médecine
contemporaine pour son recours à de
l'adn d'extraterrestres intéressante
hypothèse mais qui n'a pas encore été
validé par ses pairs elle affirmé dans
la vidéo que les masses ne servent à
rien puisque le traitement contre le co
lead existe à base d'hydroquinone rockin
twitter youtube et facebook ont donc
gagné la vidéo à cause de ces deux
fausses informations
il y à la prévention et le remède alors
il ne s'agit pas de parler de masques ou
de confinement mettons nos enseignants
c'est hydroxy chloroquine et les
médecins constituant ce groupe très
critiquée pédiatre urgentiste
ophtalmologues sont avant tout des mini
camps politiques proches du parti
conservateur tea party exigent depuis
des semaines la fin du confinement et la
réouverture de l'économie américaine ce
battage sur les réseaux sociaux a porté
ses fruits
le vice-président my peines qui refusait
encore il ya peu de porter le masque
lors d'une visite dans un hôpital aurait
reçu le 28 juillet
deux représentants de cette association
embarrassante il lui aurait demandé
d'autoriser les médecins à prescrire de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine et pourquoi la
molécule cher au professeur raoul est
elle devenue un casus belli politique
aux etats unis
on va séparer les questions de la
campagne de tremper son utilisation de
débats et le débat lui même hors de 30
il y a aussi une méfiance très grande
vers les expertes vers les scientifiques
et et un complexe médiatique qui vendent
ces messages de la peur et parfois
rejouer sur l'ignorance des gens
la guerre de l'information sur l'idh
roxy chloroquine est donc en plein pic
aux états unis peut-être serait-il temps
de demander à didier raoul s'il n'a pas
aussi dans ses tiroirs un calmant pour
apaiser les esprits américains un peu
échauffés par les guerres de tranchées
mais on va rester sur ce thème de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine puisque la
bataille entre médecins continuent en
france le professeur didier roules tu as
décidé de porter plainte contre le
directeur de l'assistance publique des
hôpitaux de paris
martin hirsch avait accusé le directeur
de liège chu de marseille de faux
témoignage lors de son audition à
l'assemblée nationale
retour en images sur ces événements
regarder
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais
mais on reste en france avec le port du
masque qui devient obligatoire en
extérieur dans la vieille ville de saint
malo en bretagne une décision prise par
la mairie le port du masque à
l'extérieur est de plus en plus souvent
imposée par les communes françaises
l'adjointe à la santé à paris a
recommandé le recommande vivement mais
pour l'instant a pas d'obligation au
niveau national de nouveaux foyers de
contamination ont été découverts et la
hausse du nombre de nouveaux cas se
poursuit sur le territoire à 1400 en 24
heures et à 15 décès jean castex annonce
le déblocage de 600 millions d'euros en
faveur des régions afin de préserver
leur capacité d'investissement à la
suite de la crise du coronavirus une
annonce saluée par renaud muselier
président de l'association des régions
de france
elle s'est donc une main tendue de
l'exécutif au territoire après à
plusieurs mois de désaccord on va faire
taire toutes nos guerres toutes nos
différences légitimes a plaidé le
premier ministre
écoutez le l'objectif
en fait les scènes cesse de répéter
depuis ma prise de fonction nous sommes
face à une crise sanitaire qui dure à
une crise économique qui aidera et
l'unité des forces politiques
économiques et sociales de la nation est
indispensable pour faire face à ce qui
est devant donc on va faire tout terre
tout le haut des airs
nos différences légitimes c'est un autre
sujet pour montrer que nous savons
agir dans l'abstrait manuel mâcon vient
de nommer 18 nouveaux préfets
départementaux parmi eux à des anciens
conseillers de l'elysée matignon dès le
début de son quinquennat le chef de
l'état s'était engagé à remplacer les
hauts fonctionnaires jugés réticents à
qui sont ses fidèles collaborateurs qui
vont renouveler le corps préfectoral
éléments de réponse en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des chauffeurs de bus de la ratp
s'estiment mal protégés face aux
coronavirus des salariés à 2,5 centre
bus ont déposé un référé le tribunal de
paris elle doit rendre sa décision
demain les délégués d'organisations
rassemblement syndical réclame des
mesures pour nous pousser à fin je cite
à de protéger leur santé et celle des
voyageurs
face au risque d'infection au qu'ovide
19 et pour mehdi bou saïd à l'avocat qui
a déposé un référé au nom des élus du
personnel de la ratp
la ratp justement n'a pas fait son
maximum pour prendre toutes les
précautions possibles
objectif de cette procédure c'est qu'un
juge ordonne à la ratp de mettre en
oeuvre des mesures de prévention et de
protection des salariés mais par
ricochet aussi des usagers contre les
risques associés au risque
koffi 19 encore une fois la ratp dans
une position qui a probablement des
raisons probablement économique et
financière parce que ça coûterait
évidemment plus cher de mettre en
circulation plus de bus d'assurer un
roulement qui est différent de celui qui
est en place pour maximiser aurait été
le nombre de désinfection est minimisée
par là même le risque de contamination à
des choses et en cela nous pour payer
des véritables mesures avec une portée
collective et non pas seulement chaque
salarié qui doit assurer sa santé mais
que des gens fassent le nécessaire pour
que collectivement les salariés et les
usa
g soit suffisamment protégé mais l'on
économique dramatique pour les
entreprises françaises et européennes
depuis le début de l'année les grands
groupes ont publié le montant de leurs
pertes sur les derniers mois perte
astronomique importe au talent mais
également pour renault plus de 7
milliards d'euros pour le constructeur
automobile au premier semestre la
situation aussi compliquée pour edf
et face à ce phénomène la courbe du
chômage pourrait-elle rapidement évoluer
et des plans sociaux ont été annoncés en
france et dans d'autres pays européens
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi déjà
augmenté durant le mois de juin a les
détails en images
[Musique]
à
le sénat italien a voté la levée de
l'immunité de matteo salvini ouvrant la
voie à d'éventuelles accusations contre
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur pour
avoir refusé l'autorisation à 164
migrants de descendre d'un navire en
sicile c'était au mois d'août dernier au
cours de ses 14 ans en tant que ministre
de l'intérieur à matteo salvini a refusé
à plusieurs reprises aux navires
transportant des migrants l'accès aux
ports italiens elle le flux de migrants
dans le pays est toujours d'actualité
onze mille d'entre eux ont débarqué en
italie la semaine dernière
regardez ce sujet de cyrielle bouille
l'italie au bord de l'implosion
frappé de plein fouet par le coronavirus
la péninsule n'arrive plus à suivre le
rythme face aux centaines de migrants
qui continuent d'affluer dans le sud du
pays ce lundi près de 200 migrants se
sont enfuis d'un centre de détention
brisant ainsi la quarantaine qui leur
était imposé en sicile face à ce
comportement
le ministre italien des affaires
étrangères a tenu à souligner
l'importance du respect de tous des
consignes sanitaires le virus n'est pas
derrière nous les citoyens italiens
comme moi doivent respecter les règles
que nous avons nous-mêmes établi et
c'est aussi valable pour les touristes
comme pour ceux qui bénéficient du droit
à la protection internationale
selon le ministère de l'intérieur la
plupart des migrants ont été retrouvés
mais certains sont toujours en fuite
une situation qui préoccupe les maires
de porto mp doc les élans beddouza en
première ligne face aux flux de migrants
de la sécurité et la santé des gens sont
les choses les plus importantes et tout
le monde doit y contribuer nous ne
comprenons pas pourquoi porto un bébé
doc les est le seul port italien où
débarquent les migrants à alerter sur
les migrants en fuite
et quand je suis venu sur place j'ai vu
une mère et son enfant partir dans une
ambulance un centre comme celui ci
conçue exclusivement pour être
provisoire pour un transfert rapide ne
peut pas être utilisé pour un long
séjour
aujourd'hui comme nous sommes toujours
confrontés aux kovy 19
les gens ont tellement peur que
lorsqu'ils voient un migrant marcher
dans la rue elle cela devient un
problème d'ordre public
la preuve c'est que je reçois
constamment des appels chaque fois que
le centre pour migrants est plein et que
quelqu'un sort et son échappement pour
mieux contrôler les flux migratoire en
méditerranée
le gouvernement italien récemment
accordé des fonds aux gardes-côtes
libyens
une décision qui a suscité l'indignation
des ong et groupes de défense des droits
de l'homme ces derniers ont manifesté ce
lundi à rome
il accuse le gouvernement italien de
complicité dans le trafic d'êtres
humains et la torture les soi-disant
gardes côtes sont une entité para
militaires et para criminels qui fait
partie de l'organisation sophistiqué de
traite des êtres humains qui contrôle
les vagues de migrants méditerranée
justice comme les flux d'immigrés ne
médite en juste que la politique du
gouvernement italien et des autres
gouvernements européens visent
uniquement à stopper les vagues
d'immigration sans vraiment se soucier
de la condition et des droits des
personnes qui veulent traverser la
méditerranée au cours des derniers mois
nous avons trouvé trois dépouilles dans
la mer et de nombreux autres fois nous
avons été témoins de rejets illégaux
vers la libye effectuée avec le soutien
des autorités italiennes et maltaises
l'italie tire la sonnette d'alarmé face
à ces flux difficile à contenir
ce mercredi les garde côtes italiens ont
déclaré avoir secouru une centaine de
migrants en détresse au large de la
libye
aucun autre pays compétent n'aurait
voulu intervenir
et justement on va faire un point sur la
situation en italie avec matteo
ghisalberti rédacteur en chef de putsch
médias bonsoir de matteo ghisalberti
merci d'être avec nous ce soir sur rtl
france alors on vient de le dire les
sénateurs se sont réunis aujourd'hui
pour voter la fin de l'immunité
parlementaire pour matteo salvini
première question tout simplement
quelles vont être les conséquences de
cette décision que monsieur slovénie
sera soumis à un procès mais je pense
aussi qu'il y aura beaucoup de
conséquences politiques de haut niveau
déjà au niveau du gouvernement parce que
il ne faut pas oublier que le
gouvernement à partir du président du
conseil des ministres risque d'être de
devenir l'objet des procédures
judiciaires pour la gestion de la crise
sanitaire liée aux coûts vide
le président du conseil des ministres a
déjà été entendu par des juges les juges
de la ville de bergame où il y a eu le
pic de cette épidémie
né en chine et donc on pourrait se
retrouver d'ici quelques mois dans des
situations similaires donc ça serait
difficile de justifier une non
autorisation une onde les v est de
l'immunité parlementaire pour des
membres du gouvernement actuel alors que
pour un matin salvini c'est lé cas
et puis il ne faut pas oublier les
effets dans l'opinion publique il y a
quelques semaines on avait appris
travers notamment un quotidien celui qui
s'appelle la verità des des échanges
entre des magistrats qui à l'époque des
ces débarquements qui avait été un péché
par le ministre matteo salvini avait dit
matteo salvini a raison mais nous devons
le juger quand même donc on voit qu'il y
a quand même une dimension politique
dimension de lutte politique contre
matteo salvini on peut penser ce qu'on
veut de lui
mais c'est assez qu'ils ne freinent
cette situation où on voit un parlement
enseignants qui donnent une autorisation
pour conduire ouvrir un procès contre
l'un des ses membres et en revanche on
voit que la magistrature n'est pas
toujours indépendante ou en tout cas
cette position d'équidistance vis-à-vis
des des raisons de politique alors
matteo salvini va être poursuivi un pur
sic et séquestration de personne
aggravée est-ce que les sanctions
peuvent être lourdes contre lui
théoriquement oui mais il ne faut pas
oublier qui il était le ministre de
l'intérieur donc le ministre de
l'intérieur dans la plupart des pays du
monde et c'est lui qui doit garantir la
sécurité du sur le territoire national
et c'est ce qu'il était en train de
faire d'ailleurs il ne faut pas oublier
non plus que la décision avait été aussi
partagé par une partie du gouvernement
de l'époque qui était le gouvernement de
comptez 1 donc c'est un peu je répète
une situation peu schizophrène parce que
il ya clairement un jugement politique
qui voudrait être utilisé pour pouvoir
battre année un ennemi qui
potentiellement pourrait remporter des
élections et montre aussi la faiblesse
de l'actuel gouvernement qui dépend
d'une majorité très très effiloché
surtout au sénat alors on a vu un le
flux migratoire continue d'augmenter en
italie même en cette période de crise
sanitaire comment comment on peut
l'expliquer tout simplement parce que il
y a les ong qui continue à vouloir aider
les conduire les situations plus
extrêmes
bien sûr il ya effectivement une
exigence de secours vis-à-vis d'eux des
milliers des personnes qui se trouvent
dans le nord de l'afrique
mais en même moment on sait qu'il y a
aussi des problèmes on sait pas où
s'arrête la conduire les bonnes
intentions et où arrive où commence en
réalité les trafics d'êtres humains et
des passeurs donc c'est très compliqué
de comprendre si on est en train de
faire du bien ou en train de faire du
mal
là il y à quelques instants je vu passer
des images qui ont fait débattre en
italie parce qu'on a vu des personnes
qui arrivent et se présentant comme des
réfugiés mais qui arrivait avec un une
caniche donc comme si c'était un peu de
touristes on voit que d'ailleurs il y a
quelques semaines quand il y avait des
soupes sont plus importants mais qui
sont en train de recommencer
sur l'état de santé en ce qui concerne
le coc vide des certains migrants
le gouvernement actuel avait fait
exactement ce que que sa fille n'y a
fait il ya un an donc il avait fait
arriver sur la côte les navires mais il
avait transféré immédiatement les
migrants sur un bateau affrété pour être
une sorte de deux zones de conduire des
des contrôles d état sanitaire des
migrants
donc on voit que le problème de la dé
l'immigration clandestine va devenir de
plus en plus importants et les italiens
auront du mal à comprendre pourquoi ils
ont dû rester confiné pendant des mois
et pourquoi elle doit porter des masques
un peu partout alors que des personnes
qui ne respectent pas ces règles et qui
sont potentiellement aussi malades
peuvent heure circule est ce un problème
sur le territoire national merci
beaucoup ma théorie alberti d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de putsch médias merci beaucoup
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
beaucoup d'avoir suivi prochain point
sur l'actualité dans un peu plus à 2 à
30 minutes rester avec nous sur arte
france
[Musique]
le bolide a été le révélateur le monstre
aux pieds d'argile bien nous sommes la
france et je l'éteins elle veut devenir
veut partout mais n'a pas les moyens ma
critique et d'un de ce que notre
continuant à nier l'évidence c'est à
dire nos continuer à mentir sur la
réalité de notre pouvoir qui est devenu
comme théâtre donne est ce que cette
france là vous fait moins peur que celle
que vous avez décrit ce peuple nomade de
la france dont j'ai peur c'est 2 du ca
qui pourrait pas très réservé entre les
mots pays
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise du corona vie